[Music]
it's been said that music and tending to
the earth can nurture one's soul but one
artist in the united kingdom is
combining the two using technology to
sprout new sounds from the flora that
surrounds us the bbc's ian haslam has
the story
[Music]
what you're hearing is plant music and
here is the man behind it i've always
from a sound perspective been interested
in listening to things
and both as a musician and somebody
who's interested in sound
just finding new ways to experience the
living
world i attach the sensors to the to the
leaves or the roots of a tree or a plant
um and then the computer that i use
measures those electrical voltages and
then it converts those voltages into
notes
and then those notes are spat out onto a
synthesizer
and then i can manipulate process
rearrange
and compose
this is what one of his compositions
sounds like
and now he's creating a new piece with
local poets providing lyrics and to
really recognize a plan as
a peer almost is
definitely new and definitely kind of
awe-inspiring gotta keep an eye on this
planet it's gonna be getting an ego soon
isn't it yeah i think so
yeah being having its own entourage of
shrubbery
strawberry
we have divorced ourselves from nature
somehow made it external to us
an arrogance that has absolutely magpies
while shutting the dirt
that's lushman they always blow me away
which is why i wanted to bring them in
on this project of in our nature
manchester um because they i feel like
they are the perfect voices
for being able to articulate the
different things that happen in and
around manchester i've got to ask can we
call this robert plant
can you call it what robert plant robert
plan
[Music]
it's almost like it's got a life of its
own has it got a life of its own i think
it does have a life of its own i think
that's what's amazing what jason shared
with us today my mum used to have one of
them in their house actually oh spider
plants yeah in the 80s yeah i said a lot
of people have those plants and you just
think how many of them are in offices
like we said in houses could have
brought it over and done a duet
i'm going to have a go at doing this
myself now putting an electrode on this
leaf let's see if i can get some musical
vibe
[Music]
whoa
i hereby name this
leaf richards
why is this the future of music do you
think i guess all music could take a
leap out of his book when it comes to
the leaf out of his leaf of his book
about how yeah what nature does sound
like
whether it responds to what i say to it
or
it's you know other things i don't know
but i'm also like the fact that i don't
know a musical mystery then for cbs
saturday morning ian haslam bbc news
[Music]
leaf richard
robert plant yeah he didn't really roll
with that did he no
but i liked that part of the robert
plant joke it was good i liked it you
know hook up the electrodes to your
garden when you go home
we'll come over and try that at your
house